all right this video comes from decoy
voice like his stuff let's check it out
the American streamer in Japan that
claimed he was Somalian filmed himself
committing crimes with his friend not
once but several times on live stream
eventually Not only was he arrested but
his copycat accomplice was as well now
the original streamer has continuously
been arrested released and arrested
again for months now but curiously his
friend has been released and is not only
streaming again but laughing about the
not Somalian guy that Still Remains
Behind
Bars why am I laughing bro who that's
not he's probably going to be in jail
for another two is two is to six months
in jail yeah y'all didn't see the videos
of John Somali basically trolling the
Japanese people being obnoxious being a
nuisance things you cannot do in Japan
legally well he got arrested and Japan
ain't like America you know even though
these places have a bit of a western
reputation their Justice systems don't
work like every other country over there
they can hold this [__]
indefinitely which you guys might see as
a violation of his rights but you got to
understand you chose that country you
knew what it was and if you didn't
that's your problem the ignorance of the
law is not an excuse for you breaking it
okay y'all want to go to these countries
[__] around and find out you're not
going to get no sympathy for my ass
especially with the [__] you was doing I
was glad when they knocked him out I was
glad when people was dragging him to the
streets and I'm also glad when police
are going to just keep him in jail so
you want to keep [__] around we want
to profit off making Japanese citizens
lives miserable when you a [__] guest
stay in prison stupid I'm not going to
feel no sympathy so they gonna hold him
right and this guy's out right now my my
opinion either he snitched or he cut a
deal but I'm sure he not going to do
none of that same dumb [__] he was doing
before cuz he was also in the streets
with him doing a lot of this IRL
streaming where these people go outside
and be a public nuisance in countries
that don't belong to them also you went
in a country that's not yours and you
involved the yakas now the police got to
deal with the Yakuza dealing with a kid
or so the police is going to handle you
they're not going to let they're not
going to let Yus handle with that's way
too much heat that's way too much people
talking about bad about the country so
the police going to take care of you and
yeah for two to 6
months I'll say something else too my
North American brothers and sisters you
guys may not realize it but most of
these countries are tiny in comparison
to us over here what does that mean they
they live differently they got cctvs
everywhere cameras on every corner at
every corner store so they are tracking
things on a level that we will never see
here in North America everything's so
spread out so you can't get away with
much without getting caught cameras are
everywhere they're using every bit of pH
so if you [__] around they going to find
out and they going to make sure they
know every time you [__] around see
here sometimes when I example here you
fly you fly a drone they catch you they
catch a drone they link into you they
give you a fine if they catch the Drone
or if you crash it right I have one of
my friends one of our friends actually
yeah that went to one of those countries
that they were not they didn't they
couldn't fly a drone they flew the drone
over there they got guns that will take
oh di on your drone M and if they find
you then they do whatever to you they
didn't find you it's just crashing a r
but something that we won't do here we
pew pew yeah we told you know [__] your
drone they they're on another the
technology is astonishing like you said
the CCTV is it it's another level yeah
[__] around and find out I'm fresh I'm
fit I'm mized and
monetized when people look at you they
judge you they judge you on your height
they judge you on your looks they judge
you on your smell and best believe they
judge you on your skin now look I'm not
talking about putting on foundation and
doing all this other crazy stuff but
it's okay to have nice smooth skin you
like being touched you like being
caressed some of you don't know what
that's like it's okay someday and that's
where today's sponsor come into play t
Henley I got smooth skin ladies they
touch it they be like oh your Skin's
softer than
mine yeah it is and listen if you're
anything like me learning about
different products and what you got to
it's too much so T Henley makes it
simple they got a level one box you grab
it it comes with instructions inside the
box that are simple to use and you just
go through the process besides amazing
skin T Henley members enjoy 20% off
retail price plus the ability to pause
or cancel at any point during their
membership because T Henley sponsoring
today's video you get 30% off your first
box plus a free gift on us click on the
link below get yourself set to have a
better
skin people judge you on your possession
people judge you on your skin get it now
listen this is your opportunity use
these products start looking fresh and
fit make sure your skin shine like
pearls
so uh yeah I don't know I can imagine
what this is going through he got to be
his booty I'm trying to tell you oh I
can't answer if I'm still in Japan or
not so his not so cryptic message claims
that he is still in Japan but his view
on nuisance streaming in the country has
completely changed I will no longer be
streaming IRL in Japan look now a lot of
you guys can call me
a if you guys knew how hard the police
were on my how many videos they had of
me and Johnny like I said they track
everything bro I mean look at all the
other iro streamers sus is never going
back to Japan homeless I'm pretty sure
is probably never streaming show quit I
don't know where the show went swimmer
Nick got banned Now isn't that
interesting that harsh criminal
punishments not only stopped the serial
offender from reoffending but
discouraged all other instances of the
same crime it's almost like the justice
system works exactly the way it's
intended if you let it because for
whatever reason Western Society decided
that they no longer had the stomach to
watch criminals suffer consequences as
the elephant in the room is why is this
guy out but not the other guy they
documented themselves committing
trespass several times together they got
arrested pretty much together and with
Japan's record of having a 99.8%
conviction
rate
that rate is
crazy I love it that rate I love it
99.8% welcome to today's game show what
would you like to do play stupid games
Win stupid prizes That's Right
contestant number one Johnny Somali how
would you like a jail sentence in Japan
99.8 is crazy my guy well enjo your
stupid prize I love it and they were
looking at three years present time for
their crimes one of them is out laughing
about how Ironclad the case is against
his accomplice and is still hanging out
in the country while no longer able to
make any money streaming I don't think
he's taking a vacation as much as he's
about to sing some courtroom karaoke and
sadly that's what needed to happen as a
first guy had been bothering the
Japanese for half a year whenever he
would get scared he would pretend to
apologize sincerely apologize to the
country and the people of Japan it was
wrong it was disrespectful then go right
back to nuisance streams but now
inspiring more streamers seeking out
Japan to Panhandle pennies online so now
the Japanese have been cracking down
these types with the live door article
Loosely translates to railway companies
possibly restricting filming
specifically targeting filming for the
purpose of commercial activities
targeting not only the nuisance
streamers but those streaming themselves
stopping those nuisance streamers as you
can remember the band of Japanese guys
that went after the American
troublemakers where the guy in a blonde
wig had a very specific tactic to use
against
him that man got
naked yeah that's crazy what do you mean
guy naked he just shipped his clothes
mhm you can't do that on stream so
they're trying to shut down the stream
by
that hey that's different the Japanese
haven't been conditioned to compete in
the oppression Olympics at least they
haven't put me in handcuffs yet like
they would in America
bro are you guys
serious that's
racist my skin color no no my skin color
my skin color I'm American my skin color
my skin color no my skin color my skin
color my skin color as apparently this
guy was getting his bike checked for
registration but then posted the video
on Tik Tok complaining that the Japanese
police were being racists tagging BLM to
which people replied on Twitter this is
just what happens to everybody's bike in
Japan where in large cities they will
just randomly check you for your papers
and had done so for decades with others
explaining that this isn't about race
it's about assimilating to Japanese
culture because when you look at the
Japanese YouTuber tekashi in Japan he
interviews foreigners talking about this
all of the time they tend to be the kind
of Foreigner that is loud kind of get
looked down on by Japanese people and
that reflects on the rest of us like all
foreigners get used to not being a lowed
foreigner get used to being
as it seems most non-japanese feel
pressured to fit into the more docile
Society but they do appreciate what it
is compared to the West no danger
whatsoever people here in Japan are very
nice it really shocked me with how
polite everyone is here versus America
so no wonder stores in Tokyo can be left
entirely unattended under the assumption
that you'll pay for your goods and go
meanwhile in the states everything must
be locked down that's actually a really
good point like some people don't
realize it but even here in Canada like
I don't feel that they need to lock my
front
door I really don't depending on what
area you're in you really don't have to
yeah you don't live in a passing area so
I can understand that yeah don't get me
wrong if you to live in the migil ghetto
or some [__] yeah you won't get blck
your [__] but everything is contextual
to the area right there's a huge
homeless population they got their
problems over there that's different
there's a couple of places I would but
most of Canada you don't need to lock
your doors and that's most of Canada
that is absolutely a k most of yeah most
of Canada most of can Canada so could
you say the same for most of America
some suburbs sure but in a lot of places
absolutely not and that's also true for
a lot of other places that are very
dangerous but the trade-off is more
freedoms you get to do more stuff
everybody has to make their choices my
only point is the same way foreigners
have to come to America and respect the
fact that you guys have more freedoms
and so it's a little bit more of the
Wild Wild West when you travel to their
countries you can't go there and impose
yourself and expect the same kind of
freedoms that's just not the way it
works I don't go to my friend's place
and expect [__] Curry when he serving
to the C in that same token I don't go
to P's place and be like where's my tuna
C who would order tuna C I don't know
but you get my point you know what I'm
saying it's really just when you go you
go inside someone's house you take your
shoes off okay common sense and just
respect if it's their rules if their
carpets are more dirty than your shoes
keep your shoes
on cuz some places y'all don't clean I
ain't take it off Sho if you and if you
and if you don't want to take off your
shoes don't go to that person's Place
true that's also another abide by the
rules don't go there yeah but you can't
have trash on the floor telling me to
take off my shoes uh
no no I ain't about to dirty my socks so
you know what I'm saying you know when
you have to do that yay you to [__] no
no absolutely not so any I just want to
say that
um this IRL phenomenon I'm I'm looking
forward to die for it to die like all
these IRL streamers um a lot of them I
don't like what they do cuz a lot of
stuff is just being a public nuisance
yeah they want to raise the people like
they want people to watch and to keep
them the best way to keep them is to
have drama it's it's like it's like the
next evolution of the pranksters now is
the IRL streamers right it's basically
people feeding off a lot of other
people's reactions to the people uh who
are making the content and I'm just not
a big fan of what I've seen from a lot
of them now of course you want to IRL
stream the fact that you're going to the
grocery store you're doing some basic
stuff fine nothing wrong but people go
around being a nuisance and then
streaming at the same time like I don't
know it's completely cringe to me and
I'm glad a lot of countries are starting
to Outlaw it because you shouldn't be
able to profit off of menacing a
population or being a nuisance to a
bunch of people you shouldn't be able to
make money off their reactions and all
that stuff and I feel the same way about
pranksters so that's my
thoughts let's know let us know what you
guys think in the comments